we were approached by the executive
producer of Wired he just feels our
audiences are perfectly matched so he
goes the concept is you guys shoot the
creation of the ultimate cosplay
walk-around robot you want him to be 10
foot tall if we can hit 10 feet that
degre we could build a head on top of
his head and give them I just make it
big and impressive for what it is it's
gonna be massive it is gonna be so
grueling it's one of those things yeah
we're gonna do what we've done this
first face unless we're gonna do
sketching and I think we needs to be
pretty loose this thing had to be worn
and moved by a single puppeteer we need
to make a lightweight so I think a lot
of us were thinking and that you know
right from the beginning from design
stage is how can we get away with making
this thing look big and heavy and an
ominous and menacing and still make it
lightweight and maneuverable one
approach is to actually have his arms be
the arms direct control of the arms of
this of this robot the other option
which I'm leaning toward is having four
arms on the robot because there's a rig
that they're going to be playing with
that will allow him to have a one of two
configurations either his arms will be
out and cloaked in armor so that they'd
all be in essence robot hands and then
he'll have a larger set of arms that
would
up here around the shoulder area so he
would have like you know a forearm
robots a huge fan of the Winston studio
party their terminator all those things
were always massive influences so I
thought it would be great to include
some of that into the design kind of had
a little bit of a predator Liberty but
Terminator feel especially if the dreads
and that Hotel even just angles of the
face for me it was like Japanese ganda
more like macros Oh type of design stuff
but it turned out to be like more like
hokey robot military design military
color just doing like little small tiny
line like this it's gonna make it so
much different hello hey guys there's a
lot of really cool stuff here you're
looking at 27 versus 25 I like the looks
longing and it's a little bit more full
player it gives a sense of ominous
strength seems like the shoulders are
good if there are a couple different
aesthetics and then we can just assist
us we can all decide to go this
direction Matt what do you guys hey you
guys feel about these don't you didn't
weigh in on these at all honestly for me
as gets me the most excited as his Tarn
else I just dig the broad shoulder low
head it's not as busy I think these are
all cool guys I really do but I just
responded to to 125 there yeah yeah we
had to make quick decisions and
fortunately that's something that all of
us have experienced doing you have to
kind of trust your gut and and move
forward and that was this whole project
we had to have that confidence let's see
if you guys like it do that kid
tonight I mean it's a collaboration you
know everybody speaks their mind and has
some input as to what something can be
and generally the person with the best
idea gets the you know approval on what
that thing should be well if we agree
upon you know this is direction a lot of
flush it out a bit more yeah and when we
settled on with the basic look of the
but the character would be that's when
it all honed in now we have a rough
concept approved Darnell did a lot of
quick 3d modeling of his rough to the
design Jim put it all together and and
went in with color schemes and finessing
like that took in some Adam Ross's work
took in a little bit of Wands it was
really cobbling the best of things and
then it was off to the races with
printing it up to start building the
prototype we still have some more
designed to do but this just gives them
a jumpstart on the basic scale that's it
I just sent it to the printer
you